keeping up Trump here and says keeping
up Trump here and says since screeching
hobos filthy lice ravaged ballsack
that's been dragged over a urine-soaked
truck stop toilet and repeatedly slapped
with a greasy maggot covered slice of
pizza pulled out of a flaming dumpster
and covered in mutant deer ticks created
in a steroid Factory half of the
technicians were off all night getting
buzzed off cough syrup Donald Trump the
internet can't get enough at digging up
his embarrassing old television
appearances what's the latest Trump clip
to go viral
eh Trump awkwardly playing beach
volleyball beat Trump awkwardly playing
air guitar to cheap trick concert see
Trump awkwardly sacrificing a goat in
order to please the ancient Dark Gods
Annie
Trump awkwardly playing air guitar at a
cheap trick concert let's find out here
it is your moment of Zen
well his hat looks great I like that
spry teenage boy who introduced the clip
who was that think he'd hit a volleyball
with those little pin hands how does he
look worse back then every girl that
like wants to be a gold digger like
these are the guys you have to just
finish grad school no here's this
slightly more dynamic vine complete with
a Top Gun soundtrack that Kyle Griffin
posted a Twitter
looks like Matteo Lane the safety zone
who needs shortlist Tom Cruise when you
count those perky man boobs bouncing up
and down and that saucy polo shirt
oh is it out no it's tucked all the way
in those jeans